Good morning, John! That is, if the world still exists. If the world does not exist
anymore, then bad morning, John, very bad morning. But assuming that the world has
not been destroyed by the kind of crazy that would be hilarious if it wasn't so
freaking terrible, let's see what the world wants to know about North Korea using
our old friend, Google Auto-Complete.
"Is North Korea going to bomb us?" Well that depends first on who the 'us' in
question is. If 'us' is me, then no, because their missiles can't reach me, which
is nice for me. But if the 'us' is everyone who's not inside North Korea – which I
really kinda feel like it should be – then, well, if you're in South Korea or Japan
or even Guam, they could. They almost certainly will not. North Korea is a huge fan
of the crazy threat – they've been using them for over 50 years – and though these
are kind of really extra crazy, it's pretty normal. "So why," you may be asking,
"the uptick in the crazy?" A bunch of reasons, actually.
Number 1: Recent U.N. sanctions against North Korea are pissing them off,
especially because China – who is literally North Korea's only ally – is supporting them.
2: South Korea just got a new president, and every time South Korea gets a new
president, North Korea test that president by being crazy at them.
3: Every year, the U.S. and South Korea do some joint military exercises and, as
always, increases the rhetoric that North Korea starts to spew.
And, finally, number 4: No one knows how North Korea works – at all! Like, there's
just nobody who knows how the internal political structure of Pyongyang works, and
so there may be some internal political reason for this, and we will never know.
"Is North Korea a threat?" Yes, unfortunately. First because, yeah, they've got
nuclear weapons, and they're probably the only state on Earth left that's crazy
enough to use them. But more importantly, we should all note that North Korea's
biggest threat is to its own people, who are malnourished – the average North
Korean child is 5 inches shorter than the average South Korean child.
If you are decalred to be an enemy of the state in North Korea – which is
surprisingly easy – then you go to a concentration camp, where the conditions are
just terrible, but so does your entire family, and any children that you have. They
grow up and live their entire lives in that concentration camp, and so do their
children. Three generations of people. There are people in those concentration
camps today because their grandparents sympathised with South Korea during the
Korean War. What?!
"Is North Korea communist?" No, not really. I mean, it says it right in the title.
They're a democracy – the Democratic People's Republic of Korea – and they can
vote, actually. There's only one candidate on the ballot, and if they write someone
in, they can be declared an enemy of the state, which as previously noted, can be a
very, very bad thing! So yeah, their system, they're kind of an absolute
totalitarian multi-party hereditary military dictatorship. Did I say that right?
Now on to "why does North Korea hate the U.S.?" Well first, because we supported
South Korea in the Korean War, which defines North Korea, basically. This is a
complicated story, and I don't have time to get into it, but we remain South
Korea's strongest military ally, and that, that is reason enough.
But second, and probably more importantly, military dictatorships need an enemy to
rattle their saber against, and by rattling their saber against the United
States – the strongest power in the world – they can pretend to their citizens like they are
a global power, which they are not. The people who live there have never heard
anything different, and so to them it does not seem absurd. But while most of the
citizens of North Korea are ignorant to everything that's going on outside of the
country, I mean it's the only place left on Earth where you can't buy a coke.
The leaders of the country are not – we hope – as idiotic as their rhetoric makes
them sound. They know that if they drop the bomb on another country, we would wipe
them off the map. It would be terrible for everyone, but we would do it. But these
like, tantrums – for lack of a better word – have gotten them concessions in the past,
and since everyone wants a stable Asia, and nobody wants a war in Asia, and
Pyongyang is really surprisingly unpredictable, sometimes I guess it's better to
give the screaming child what they want than to have the entire supermarket staring
at you, and feeling really uncomfortable – and again, if you keep giving them what
they want, why would they ever stop screaming? John, I'll see you on Tuesday.